the 1918 nobel prize for chemistry is
probably the most important nobel prize
ever awarded it was given to german
scientist fritz haber for solving one of
the biggest problems humanity has ever
faced
his invention is directly responsible
for the lives of four billion people
today
but when he received his prize many of
his peers refused to attend
two other nobel prize winners rejected
their awards in protest and the new york
times wrote a scathing article about him
he is simultaneously one of the most
impactful and tragic scientists of all
time
perhaps more than any other single
person he has shaped the world we live
in today
[Music]
part of this video is sponsored by ren
more about them at the end of the show
if you are an american citizen and you
find an island with a lot of bird poop
on it well then you can claim that
island for the united states and the u.s
will have your back the president is
authorized to send in the navy and the
army to defend your newly discovered
poop-covered island there are currently
10 american islands that were claimed in
this way
and even though the law that made this
possible was passed in 1856
it is still in effect to this day so why
did people want poop-covered islands so
badly
[Music]
there are a few dozen islands off the
coast of peru where millions of seabirds
gather to mate
the waters near the island are full of
fish and these millions of birds eat the
fish
and then they poop
a lot
since the region is hot and dry this
poop solidifies and accumulates over
millennia
there are cliffs of bird poop 30 meters
or a hundred feet high
[Music]
technically bird poop is called guano
and by the mid-1800s buying and selling
bird guano was big business
the price rose as high as 76 dollars per
pound
meaning you could trade four pounds of
guano for one pound of gold
so why was there such a big market for
bird poop well to answer that we have to
look inside the human body
by weight most of our bodies are made up
of oxygen carbon and hydrogen
but the fourth most common element is
nitrogen
nitrogen is part of the amino acids that
form proteins it's part of hemoglobin
the compound that carries oxygen and red
blood cells and it's a central component
of dna and rna
nitrogen is essential for all life on
earth we get our nitrogen by eating
plants or animals which have eaten
plants and plants get their nitrogen
from the soil
the problem is if you farm the same soil
year after year you harvest the nitrogen
out of it and eventually there isn't
enough nitrogen for healthy plants to
grow
they can't produce enough chlorophyll to
photosynthesize which stunts their
growth
their leaves turn yellow and they are
more susceptible to pests and disease
crucially for farmers nitrogen
deficiency means smaller yields
the way to fix this is to add nitrogen
back into the soil
which is where bird guano comes in
guano is up to 20 percent nitrogen
hundreds of years ago incan farmers
realized that adding guano to their soil
made crops grow taller this is what
allowed them to grow food in places that
were previously unfarmable and expand
their empire
south america's rich deposits of bird
poop did not go unnoticed by the rest of
the world in 1865 spain went to war
against its former colonies of peru
chile ecuador and bolivia for control of
their guano-laden islands
but such was the world's appetite for
nitrogen that by
1872 guano was running out and peru
banned further exports the world would
need another way to get its nitrogen
fixed
[Music]
this was a crisis
william crooks a british chemist made a
dire prophecy in 1898
with the world's growing population and
dwindling supplies of nitrogen he said
we stand in deadly peril of not having
enough to eat in less than 30 years time
he argued people all over the world will
be dying of starvation
but he also proposed a solution
it is the chemist who must come to the
rescue it is through the laboratory that
starvation may ultimately be turned into
plenty
because here's the thing
nitrogen isn't rare it's common
78
of the air is nitrogen
but it's in a form that plants and
animals can't use
two atoms of nitrogen triple bonded
together
this bond is one of the strongest in
nature
the way to measure the strength of a
chemical bond is by the amount of energy
that's required to break it so to break
apart two chlorine atoms for example
would take two and a half electron volts
to break apart two carbons requires 3.8
ev
two oxygens 5.2 ev but to break apart
two atoms of nitrogen requires 9.8
electron volts a tremendous amount of
energy
there are two processes that do this
naturally
lightning releases so much energy it
breaks apart n2 into individual nitrogen
atoms
they then quickly react to form nitrogen
oxides
these molecules stay in the atmosphere
until they react with water droplets in
clouds and fall to the ground in rain
there are also a few types of bacteria
living in soil that can break the n2
bond using a tremendous amount of energy
to do so
they make nitrogen available for plants
but bacteria only replenish the nitrogen
slowly and there's not enough lightning
to produce nitrogen compounds at scale
so chemists tried
in 1811 georgic hildebrandt mixed
nitrogen and hydrogen in a sealed flask
trying to make ammonia one of the
nitrogen-containing molecules found in
guano
when that didn't work he submerged the
flask 300 meters underwater to increase
the pressure
that didn't work either but he was on
the right track
increasingly sophisticated versions of
these experiments were carried out over
the following hundred years
all of them failed
so when fritz haber became interested in
this problem in 1904 he was joining a
long line of failed chemists
he was 36 years old working as a
low-level academic at the university of
karlsruhe he was also a new father with
a two-year-old boy named herman and a
wife clara who was one of the first
women to get a phd in chemistry
driven by pride and competition with
another scientist haber spent five years
on the problem
his idea was to combine nitrogen and
hydrogen not only at high pressure but
also at high temperature and in the
presence of a catalyst something that
lowers the amount of energy required to
split diatomic nitrogen
to do this new experimental apparatus
had to be invented haber worked
tirelessly on this project building
equipment that could tolerate ever
higher temperatures and pressures
he also got lucky at the time he was
moonlighting as a technical consultant
for a light bulb manufacturer
so there he had access to lots of really
hard to find materials like the element
osmium
osmium is rare in his day there was only
about 100 kilograms of the refined metal
in existence
but the company he worked for was
experimenting with using it for
filaments in their light bulbs so they
had most of the world's supply
harper suspected it might make the
perfect catalyst so he brought a sample
back to his lab
and there in the third week of march
1909 haber placed his sheet of osmium in
the pressure chamber
and then he pressurized and heated the
nitrogen and hydrogen to 200 atmospheres
and 500 degrees celsius
under these conditions the triple bonds
broke apart and nitrogen reacted with
hydrogen
of the total gas mixture six percent
turned into ammonia
when the gas was cooled one milliliter
of ammonia dripped out the end of a
narrow tube into a beaker
an elated hobber rushed from one lab to
another yelling come on down
there's ammonia
germany's biggest chemical company basf
commercialized hobbers process within
four years they had opened a factory in
oppao producing five tons of ammonia per
day
[Music]
people spoke of making bread from the
air
[Music]
with the fertilizer from this industrial
process on the same plot of land farmers
were able to grow four times as much
food
and as a result the population of the
earth quadrupled
there's a good chance you owe your life
to hauber's invention
the earth supports 4 billion more people
today than it could without nitrogen
fertilizer
in fact around 50 percent of the
nitrogen atoms in your body
came from the harbor process
the invention made fritz haber a wealthy
man
he got a promotion becoming the founding
director of the kaiser wilhelm institute
for physical chemistry in berlin
he also befriended some of the best
scientists of his day including max
planck max born and albert einstein
after einstein separated from his first
wife in 1914 he stayed the night at
hobber's house
but if haber was so well regarded
why was he shunned by colleagues when he
won the nobel prize
well it all comes down to what happened
in world war one
when the war broke out haber volunteered
for military duty
unlike pacifist einstein who denounced
the war haber was a patriot he wanted to
use his expertise to help his country
only a few months into the war the
german army was already running out of
gunpowder and explosives ammonium
nitrate besides being an excellent
fertilizer is also an explosive
just look at what happened in beirut in
august of 2020.
[Music]
a warehouse containing almost 3 000 tons
of ammonium nitrate caught fire
and in the extreme heat the fertilizer
detonated
the blast which could be heard hundreds
of kilometers away killed at least 217
people and injured thousands more
seismometers registered an artificial
earthquake measuring 3.3 on the richter
scale
this is just one of many fertilizer
related explosions the oppa plant where
haber's process was first put into
practice would also explode in 1921
and the reason is nitrogen
we've already seen that it takes a
tremendous amount of energy to break
apart nitrogen's triple bond
but the flip side of that coin is that
when two nitrogen atoms come together
and form that bond
a huge amount of energy is released
the explosions of gunpowder tnt
nitroglycerin and ammonium nitrate all
form diatomic nitrogen gas as a product
and the formation of that triple bond is
where these chemicals derive much of
their explosive energy
haber lobbied to convert the factories
using his process to make ammonia for
fertilizer to create nitrate for
explosives instead
his superiors believed such a conversion
to be impossible but haber persisted and
soon his chemical process was at the
heart of the german war machine
from bread out of the air
to bombs out of the air
but haber thought chemistry could make
an even bigger contribution to the war
in december 1914 he witnessed a chemical
weapons test
he was unimpressed
haber believed that he could do better
he set out to make a gas that was deadly
at low concentrations and heavier than
air so it would sink into enemy trenches
projectiles carrying chemical weapons
were banned at least in theory by the
hague convention of 1899
but in practice after the start of the
war germany france and britain all
experimented with chemical weapons
haber converted his wing of the
institute into a chemical weapons
laboratory and after only a few months
of work he zeroed in on chlorine gas
an employee otto han expressed his
discomfort about the new weapon
haber told him
innumerable human lives would be saved
if the war could be ended more quickly
in this way
at 6 p.m on the 22nd of april with the
wind blowing toward the allied trenches
german troops released 168 tons of
chlorine from over 5 000 gas cylinders
the wall of gas advanced across the
battlefield
since chlorine gas is two and a half
times heavier than air it sank into the
trenches of the allied soldiers
any soldier that inhaled a lungful of
the gas
suffered a terrible death
chlorine irritates the mucous lining of
the lungs so violently that they fill
with liquid
the soldiers effectively drowned on dry
land
more than 5 000 allied soldiers died
this way in the first attack
[Music]
haber was promoted to the rank of
captain
and a week later he was back home in
berlin
on the first of may the hobbers hosted a
dinner party
and after the party wound down
fritz took sleeping pills and went to
bed
but that night his wife clara took his
gun and went outside into the garden
and there she fired a single shot into
her chest
[Music]
her 12 year old son herman heard the
shot and ran outside to find his mother
as she lay dying
[Music]
the next morning fritz haber was on a
train to the eastern front
to supervise a gas attack on the russian
army
some have claimed clara killed herself
because of her husband's obsession with
chemical weapons
and that may have been part of it
but honestly we don't know because no
first-hand accounts survive that support
this interpretation
what we do know is that clara was deeply
unhappy in her marriage
in 1910 after being married for eight
years to fritz she wrote to a friend
what fritz has won during these eight
years that and still more i have lost
and what remains ahead of me fills me
with the deepest dissatisfaction
after clara's suicide haber spent the
rest of the war running his institute
researching chemical weapons gas masks
and pesticides by 1917 the institute
employed 1500 people including 150
scientists
it was like a mini manhattan project but
for chemical weapons
in total one hundred thousand soldiers
were killed by chemical weapons in world
war one
when germany surrendered
haber was crushed all the money he made
from his ammonia patent was lost to
hyperinflation
in an attempt to pay off germany's
crippling war debt he tried to distill
gold from seawater but the project was
futile
in 1933 the nazis came to power and
passed a law that all jewish civil
servants including scientists were to be
fired from their jobs
haber was jewish but he never practiced
the religion regardless his military
service exempted him from the law but he
resigned from his role as director in
solidarity with all the jewish
scientists who worked at the institute
the next year in a hotel room in basel
switzerland he died of heart failure
immediately after world war one hobbers
institute developed a cyanide-based
insecticide
it had a barely detectable odor so they
mixed in a foul-smelling chemical to
alert people to the danger
the resulting gas was called zyklon b
a decade after haber's death the nazis
requested chemists remove the
foul-smelling component
and
this form of zyklon b the chemical
developed at habers institute was then
used to perpetrate the holocaust
thinking about this story
it would be easy to paint haber as a
villain
or as a hero
for inventing the process used to feed
half the world
but another approach
is to regard him as irrelevant to the
larger story
because
someone else would have figured out a
way to process nitrogen out of the air
and other scientists were developing
chemical weapons
over the past few centuries science and
technology
have improved our lives immeasurably
but they have also given us ever
increasing ways to destroy ourselves
i think it'd be great to believe that we
could ask scientists to only work on
problems that are good for humanity
but the reality is that every bit of
information is a potential double-edged
sword
you don't know the outcome of your
research or how it might later be used
ammonium nitrate is both a fertilizer
and an explosive
so the real question is
how do we keep increasing our knowledge
and control of the natural world
without destroying ourselves and
everything else on this planet in the
process
so chemistry has made it possible for 8
billion of us to live on this planet and
to have the standard of living that we
do
but as a byproduct we've changed the
atmosphere and now we're suffering the
consequences in the form of more
frequent and severe heat waves among
other things which brings me to an offer
directly from me to you i want to offset
one month of your carbon emissions and
i'll do it with this video's sponsor
wren
on their website you can calculate how
much carbon you emit and which
activities have the greatest impact and
if you like you can offset your
emissions through a monthly subscription
but they don't just plant trees one of
the projects they're currently backing
is a pilot study in scotland called
enhanced mineral weathering so the way
it works is they spread small basalt
rocks throughout forested areas and then
when it rains those raindrops contain
dissolved co2 in the form of carbonic
acid and when the rain hits the basalt
it reacts and the ph increases
now that turns carbonic acid into
carbonates like calcium carbonate and
that precipitates out so in this solid
mineral form the carbon is trapped
potentially for thousands of years and
this is the kind of chemical innovation
we may need to solve the climate crisis
so if you want to join me in offsetting
your carbon footprint then click the
link in the description ren is
completely transparent about where they
invest the money and they'll send you
monthly email updates if you're one of
the first hundred people to sign up i
will personally pay for your first month
of co2 offsets which is not a standard
offer it is just something i really
wanted to do so i want to thank ren for
sponsoring this part of the video and i
want to thank you for watching